the point of sharpening an ax is not to
get better at sharpening axes is to make
a sharper ax and being realistically
strong is more important than being able
to demonstrate strength on a specific
lift and so we shouldn't sacrifice real
world performance at the altar of
impressive numbers and skills don't make
skills or numbers your top priorities
sure being able to do handstand push-ups
is cool but cooler still is the shoulder
strength balance and body awareness you
get from training for that movement and
if you're rearranging your training
program to a huge extent just to achieve
one skill perhaps sacrificing entire
planes of motion so you can train Pike
push-ups three times a week then maybe
you should reconsider those priorities
and the same goes for training really
hard just to increase your bench press
by 5 kilograms maybe you could just
maintain at that point and consider
introducing something new to your
training unless you're a professional
athlete with a singularly passionate
about a particular domain of Fitness
cool skills should be nice to haves big
lifts a bonus they shouldn't be your
North Star Performance and all-round
fitness should be
bye for now